もういろんな物質の分析ね
科学的に何か役に立つものを作るとか
役に立つ説明とかあっても悪くはないんだけど
それは全部カット 単なる素粒子論だけで終わっちゃう
例えば心からいろんな物質が生まれますって言うんです
言うんだけど それだったら心をコントロールしていろんな物質を作ってしまえばすごい気持ちいいもんでしょうね
自分の心で自分の好きなものを作ってしまっちゃうんだと
それはカット教えてあげないと
その代わりに心によって物質が生まれるんだと
心によって客観的な社会が生まれるんだと
だいたいこういうこういうふうに生まれるんだと言って
そこで終わるんですね
ですから 我々の俗的な目で聞きたがっているものは言ってない
その代わりに解脱に必要なものだけ言ってるんです
ですから あくまでもアビダンマ論というのは修行者のために必要な論理章ですね
ですから 純粋な物質ではないんです
それはお坊さんたちが作ったものなんです
じゃあどうしますか？質問とかありますか？質問じゃなくていろいろ意見とかね
さっきワットとランバーナですか
説明ありましたよね 十二所ってありますよね
ゲンニビゼシニとシキショウコウミソクホウってあって
で 所縁っていうか  所縁というのはゲンニビゼシニですね
そのワットの方が  ワットはゲンニビゼシニです
所縁はシキ  シキショウコウミソクホウってそういうふうに考えちゃっていいですか？ うん
先生  はい  変化するものがあるのならば
心象は物質なんですか？ 心象は物質じゃないんですね
心象 心も変化するのは当たり前ですけど
心象は物質じゃないんです
心象が生まれると物質が生まれるんです
例えば心に怒りが 怒りが生まれたら怒りで物質が生まれるんですね
それで体も変化してしまっちゃうんですね
心に欲が生まれたら それにふさわしい物質が体中生まれちゃうんですね
物質のエネルギーが それで体は変化する
心も瞬間瞬間変化する
変化する  そうするとさっきのルーターの説明は正しくないことになる
なるほど まあまあそう言えばそうなんですけど
でも心と心はもっと大事な心には認識できるんですね
物事 それから心には空間要りませんね
ただの認識脳という働きだけだから
で 心象っていうのは認識によって生まれる感情なんですね
ですから この認識の世界と認識される世界
で 物質には何も認識できません
そこで例えばこちら小さな蝶がありますけど
それは物質ですね これには何も認識できません
この蝶が自分がいることは知りません
感情が自分が怒っていることは知らないですよね
でも自分という実感いつでもありますからね
だから  喜んでいる心は自分が喜んでいるということは知らないわけですよ
知ってるの  知ってるんです
で 自分実感がいない場合
我々はもう意識がない時なんですね
意識が消えちゃったら
もう自分がいるということさえわからない
でも 例えばすごく喜んでいる時も
やっぱり喜んでいるんだから
それが実感なんですね
その認識は別の心がやってるんじゃないんですか？タイムラグがなきゃ観察はできないんですから
喜んだ後でなきゃ喜んだっていうことがわからないですから
それ込んだ心と認識した心は別の心になっちゃいますよね
それはもうまず違うことなんですね
自分が喜んだと認識する場合は違う働きなんですね
でもこの実感というものは認識にと同義語なんですね
いわゆる認識すること自体が実感なんです
例えば喜んでいる時は喜んでいること自体が実感であって
それから私が喜んでいたんだというのは
また違う実感であって
違う認識なんです  怒りを物質って表現するんであれば
どこまでが物質で どこからが物質でないのか
うんうん 怒りは物質じゃないんです
怒りも痛みも物質じゃないんです
例えば足の痛みであろうか
それは決して物質的なものじゃないんです
で それは心の世界で で
心が例えばもう五 六キロぐらい歩くと
で つまらなくなるんですね
心にとっては 同じことやってるんだから
他のことをやりたがったりする
他のことを認識したかったりする
でもやっぱりやむを得なく歩くとかね
そういうことによって
やむを得なく歩く場合は
六キロを歩くとすごく疲れてるんですね
体が足が痛くなる そこで我々はものすごく見たいものはいっぱいあるんだと
その見たいものはいっぱい見るためには
我々はあっちこっちいろんな展示会を歩かなくちゃいけない
それで片っ端からそれを見て
次のものを見て 次のものを見てと歩くんですね
その時の計算すると 結局四キロ五キロ歩いているはずなんですけど
その時は痛みがないんですね
ですから それは心が生み出すもので
痛みっていうのは ですから
この六キロ歩くと この心はこの
嫌だ やむを得ないんだ
歩かなくちゃいけないんだという意識が生まれるたびに
それにふさわしい物質は体に生まれる
それで生まれると その物質は心が認識する
そうすると体が重いんだ
だるいんだと認識する
じゃあ重いんだ だるいんだ認識しちゃったら
足が上げるのは苦痛だと結論する
それで苦痛を味わってしまっちゃう
それは暗示の世界で それはちゃんと証明しているんだから
暗示かけて人が普段やる気はないものをやらせることはできるんだから
心に行ってしまえばもう問題はない
それで我々にコントロールできる
例えば怒り 嫉妬とか この暗い感情が生まれると
物質の組み合わせはどうせ好ましくはないと
もう考えて 明るさ それからもうね
もう慈しみの心やら そういう感情が生まれると
それで生まれる物質は体にはとてもふさわしい
いわゆる自分にとってはふさわしい物質の組み合わせだと
そういうことで感情をコントロールしなさいと
感情をコントロールしたら
まあ体の問題は放っておけと
という風な教えになってしまっちゃうんですね
それまた科学的にも同じことで
脳内革命と何とかという本でも同じ論理を言ってるんですね
で 暗い心が生まれると
脳細胞が悪い物質を出してる
毒を出しちゃうんだと
明るい感情を作ると 体に必要な脳のモルヒネという
この何とかエンドルフィンを出してくれるんだと
それを出してくれると
すごく調子が良くて よく考えると別に物体に毒出しちゃってもモルヒネ出したってもどっちでも同じことですけどね
ですからもう体のことはそんなに気にする必要ない
とにかく心のことだけ問題なんです
[背景音楽]で変化するだけで
ルーパっていうのはやっぱりいい定義じゃないんですよ
私も正直に言うならば
で まあたまたま勝手に作った定義で
僕はこれ書く時でも こちらのもういろいろ文句言いたいところいっぱいあるんです
この定義について これお釈迦様の定義でもないんです
で ただルーパという言葉を見て
ルッパティという動詞を強引に入れただけだと私も思ってるんです
変化するんだからルーパよって
でもそれよりこの論理的に見ると
エネルギーというのは変化することでエネルギーですね
それで世界も我々が知っている物質の世界っていうのは
物質は存在しているわけではなくて
いつでもエネルギーは変化して違うエネルギーに変わる
それに我々は物質と言うんですね
そこら辺はまあいくらかまあ真理性は高い
でもこの定義は大してろくないいい定義じゃないんです
ただ言葉の遊びだけですよ
正直に言うと だからこのテキストにも定義が入ってないし
また違う定義いくつかありますけど
その元のテキストはまだ今持ってないんですね
私は このこれはもう学生さんの子供たちのテキストですから
こちらではそんな厳密に定義されてないんです
ですから このあったならば
僕はまあ後でこの探してみます
他の定義あるかないか
あります 当然 とにかくこのあの
僕はこの次に次の勉強会で
このもう詳しくこの識の世界
物質の世界を説明しようと考えているんです
心の世界先に で そうすると簡単に物質のことをわかると思います
それ簡単に理解できるんです
それを理解できたら心の世界に入ろうと
心の分析は難しいんです
ですから この仏教的ではなくて
逆にやろうと 仏佛教では先に難しいことをやらせちゃう
それから簡単で 何のどういうこと考えてるかわかりませんだけど
で どんな経典を開けてもらっても
一番目は一番難しい  2番目はもう難しいと
三 四 五 六 七 八になると
別に大したことなく簡単に読める
読んで理解できる もうシステムになってるんですね
それはお釈迦様が決めたシステムじゃないんです
経典編集したのは昔のお坊さんたちだから
その昔のお坊さんたちが決めたものなんですね
一番一番先に一番難しいことを入れてやろうと
釈迦様教えた順番で三蔵経出来上がっているわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様亡くなったから
この何を教えたかと それはもう長さの順番とか内容のいろいろなことを考えて
この編集しちゃったんですね
この変数編集過程では一番わかりにくい教義はどんな教
どんな経典 テキストの中には一番目に入れているんです
だから長部経典の一番目は難しくて
長部経典の一番目はものすごい難しい
少部も同じで アビダンマになってくるとすぐ心の分析から始まるんです
何言ってるかさっぱりわからなくなっちゃうんです
これはものすごくいい本ですけどね
アビダンマの本当の拠点に開けてみると
全然読めないというか
いきなり始まるのはこの心の中でも一番難しい心をとって
その心の中身と心相の分析なんです
それでも簡単な心から難しい心に行くのは当たり前で
そうするかというと逆なんです
簡単な心は最後に来るんです
このアビダンマで皆様がこれから勉強する心の順番
アビダンマ経典になると逆さまで出てくるんです
そういう風になっているわけです
ですから 次の講義でわかりやすい物質の世界から説明始まります
じゃあまた他の何か聞きたいことを
まあ授業の形だから まあどんな疑問でもいいんです
別に 説法じゃないんだから
初縁と聞ですか？あのアーランバーナとワットの違いをもう一度
アーランバーナは外ですね
ワットは内ですね  対象は外ですね
内ということは その感覚器官ということですか
感覚器官ですね  わかりました
ただ言葉上の問題 例えば体は体を認識するときは体を外にあるわけじゃないでしょうし
その時でも一応外を通して扱っちゃう
お腹が痛いと言ってもね
例えば皮膚 皮膚でものを感じるでしょ
その場合は感じるものは外であることは当たり前に分かりやすいんですね
体の皮膚は内として what
として見ちゃう それで皮膚自体が痛くなると
それで皮膚は皮膚は皮膚を感じていることなんですね
その時はやっぱり外と言っちゃうんですね
体が体を感じる時も それから心で物を考えるでしょ
で 例えばこの前勉強したことと今日の勉強したことはなんかちょっと噛み合わないのではないかと何か考えるかもしれませんね
その場合は心の中で回転してるんですね
その時でも対象は外と言っちゃうんですね
別に外にどこにあるわけじゃないでしょ
概念だけですから ですから
一応言葉で実語を使って分けてるだけ
もうちょっとだけ さっき髪の毛
認識作用があるから生命であるっていうのが生きてるっていうことがあると
髪の毛というのは髪の毛自身が認識しないから
我々通常髪の毛も生きているような気がしますけれども
仏教の言うところの生命という考え方って
要するに髪の毛が生きてるが生きている
僕らが通常に考えるような生命っていうわけじゃなくて
認識から全部スタートするというところ
そのものだけをとっている
それを生命という言い方をしてる
我々が通常生きている生きているから
全く違う次元で話してるという
俺も科学的 いわゆる科学的に見てるだけなんですね
感情ではなくて どこから生命という実感が生まれたかというと
認識するんだからということで定まっちゃうんです
この瞑想の中でこの不浄観という瞑想があるんです
で 日本の文化ではなかなか合わない瞑想ですけど
自分の体はすごい汚い
不浄なものだと念じて観察しちゃうんですね
で その時もこの このに分けて
体の部品を体を部品ごとに分けて
なんか部品扱いなんですね
それは別に医学的に分けてないんです
我々認識できるぐらいの世界で部品に分けて
例えば唾液ありますね
唾液 はどんなものかと
唾液自体別にして観察する
そうすると唾液っていうのは気持ちいいと
すごくすごくいいものだですかと
私のものですかと これは大変な宝物ですかと
言えば もう唾液自体はもういいんだ
あれはもう汚いもので
もうちゃんと分かってる
それは私でもなんでもないんだと
不浄なものだと それに対してもう執着を捨てちゃう
じゃあ髪の毛は何ですかと
普段感覚では髪の毛はいい私のもので
すごくいいものだと思っても
それは別な部品として見る
髪の毛という部品を見ると
本当に気持ち悪いものなんですね
自分の部屋にでもあっちこっち髪の毛あったらもうすごい気持ち悪いし
で どうせ気持ち悪いもので汚いものであると
で ちょっと放っておけばもうすぐ臭くなっちゃうし
ですから髪の毛は宝物でも私のものでも私でもないんだと
それは不浄たるものであって
髪の毛には執着しませんぞと
そこはまあ決めると そういう風に一部一部部品的に見ちゃ見ちゃう
見てみる で みんな自分の心臓なんか大事にしてるでしょ
すごいいいものだと でも他の動物でも誰かものあれ切って心臓なんか持ってきたら
すごく驚いたり 気持ち悪がったりするでしょうに
で そういう場合は同じ
自分もそういう同じ心臓を持ってるんだと
そういう風に部品に分けてみたら
部品しかなくなっちゃうんですね
部品はあるんだけど その部品自体は全部不浄であるんだと
全部汚いものを見るのは嫌なものなんですね
怖いものなんですね 血液さえ見たら怖くなる人がいるんだから
そういう風に骨やら骨髄やら血液やら大便
小便 大腸 小腸 胃 胃の中のもの
心臓 肺とか いくらかまあ 三十二ぐらいに分けて瞑想すると
それのこの この自分という実感がこの体から生まれてくるんだから
じゃあ体分解してみたらどうですかと
分解して一つ一つについて正直な感情を見てくださいと
この自分の体にしたって
我々は体のものを取ってみたら
自分にとっても感情は気持ち悪い感情なんですね
自分の体の一部 例えばガンでも摘出されたならば
それをまた大事に持ってきて
金の入れ物でもね ガラスでも張っても
すごくどこかに置いておくということはおそらくしないでしょうと思いますね
見ると気持ち悪いですから
本人にも それで一部一部見るとすごい気持ち悪いところで
その気持ち悪いものは全部まとめたところで
あなたは尊い人間ですよとか
私は神様に作られた大変な立派な生命ですと
いい加減にしろと ということなんですね
汚いものは全部まとめたところでも
結果も汚いということで
このいわゆる執着心を執着する心を捨てて
やっぱり真理の世界に持っていこうではないかという一つの観察方法ですね
この 三十二 の不浄観 だからそれもこのアビダンマでもやっている
この分析して別々に見るということなんですね
ですから 我々人間 普通の人間にとっては
人間だ 生命だとか ああだとか
もうもう何を考えてるんですかと
それ誰もしっかりしてないんですね
ただ漠然として尊いだ
ありがたいだと思っているだけです
それに執着する ですから
ありがたいと思ったらどうして困るんですか
人間は汚いんだけど 神様は立派だよと思っても
別に神様は存在しないんだからいいんだけど
それでもそれに執着してしまっちゃうんです
体は無常ですけど 霊魂は永遠ですよと思っても構いません
霊魂はどうせないものだから
もうないものは永遠と言ったっても
そうでないったって問題はないんだけど
それで我々はもう試しにでもそういう概念を使わない
なぜならば 霊魂は霊魂はありがたいもので
究極的な清く神で満ち溢れているものだよだなと思っちゃったら
何か得体知れないものに執着してしまっちゃう
それで得体知れないものに執着するのはいいんだけど
これ執着しているのはこの汚い醜い不浄たる体なんですね
そんな汚い醜い不浄たる体がね
そんな理想的に何かに執着したっても
そこに行けるわけじゃないんですね
行けないんです 醜い猿さんが人間を見て
その場で実物あるんだけど
ああ 人間はいいな 立派だな
かっこいいなといくら思って執着したっても
結局ひどい目に遭うだけで猿は人間にならないんですね
かえって猿は進化して人間になったところで面白くも何ともないし
ですからこの そういうやっぱりこの尊いだという生命だとか大事だとかね
我が大事な命とかね というふうな
この大雑把な漠然としてているしっかりした根拠のない概念は
もう修行については片っ端から破る
で 我々は世俗対応は認めているんだから
社会に戻ったら落ち着いて
それなりに行動すると
社会に入ってみんなにそんなことを言いふらすことはしません
[笑い]そうするとなかなかうまくいかなくなりますからね
で 普通の人々が普通の言い方で
それでもご飯食べて美味しいですね
美味しいですよ [笑い]それはもうその条件で美味しいと認めてあげる
ですけど その人のその漠然とした考え方であって
別に美味しいという概念はあるわけじゃないということは
本人はただ知っているだけで
そこでそんなそんな説教したっても
もう全く合わないんだから
そういうことはしません
ですから この仏教のこの怖い話ですけど
なんかすごい あの なんて言いますか
もうかなり覚悟を決めないと
この仏教の本当の勉強できないぐらいの
まあまあ怖いほど分析しますよ
それでも知れば知るほど人は落ち着くんです
怖くなることはないんです
怖さは消える 恐怖感というのは普通の人にあって
仏教の人にないんです
我が命と思ったところで恐怖感が生まれてくる
なぜならば 我が命を亡くしてはいけませんだから
仏教の立場から見れば
もうこれ守るものはないんです
瞬間瞬間死ぬことに我が命と言ってるんだから
だから別に何に怖がってるんですかと
瞬間瞬間物事を変化して自分が変化して死んでいくでしょう
それに我が命というんだから
この部屋にいて またレストランに行っちゃったらすぐ心が変わるでしょうに
同時に体も変わってしまっちゃいますから
それに命というんだから
死ぬことに命と言うんですね
ですから 別に我が命と思って
それはもう怖いだ 死ぬのは嫌だということはもう消えてしまっちゃうんですね
ですから 勉強するとちょっと怖いなと思うかもしれませんけど
結局怖さが消えてしまう
で すごく強くなるんです
精神的に 怖いものを知らない状態になってしまっちゃうんです
怖いものを知らない人は別にもう何でもやりますよ
やれと言えば何でもやれることやることできるような状態なんです
そういうことで じゃあまあ長い時間どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]